welcome to this video playing letter CEO
yep right not REM okay CEO is it web no
it's Yemm okay anyway we got a queen's
gambit let's see sloth two hands play
more of that Knight f3 Knight c3 system
now okay a form yeah that I recently saw
in a game you know in a book yeah I
don't really know the screen 85 now
right no it's not doing that okay it's
nice Queenie 5 is a much more
challenging option the bishop on d6
looks a bit wrong to be perfectly honest
so is he going 45 no not really in this
particular position I can even go if
form I can take see form play hard play
45 yeah maybe if for was mistimed a
little bit the thing is he didn't really
threatened if didn't we threaten e5
anyway he has to take on c4 and play
five that's the only only option yeah
that seems okay huh what now do I go d 5
in this position that's going to be okay
for him I guess my taking is also ok ok
i expect 9 p-6 so I'm an IP 6 is very
yeah very standard there are some
interesting points though if he takes no
doesn't takes d5 there was a five I
wonder if a five as a move or not
interesting yeah I guess I guess it
makes some sense no not entirely clear
so three I guess you will go Bishop h5
but you never know can print that in any
case so night to see five probably yeah
I wonders g4 move was that crazy yet
could be a bit crazy taking on c6
doesn't seem very attractive
now that pin is quite quite annoying
down interesting yeah but it's difficult
I can go g4 but still I don't like the
idea of that move it feels feels very
weakening night h 4f five would be cool
but I don't see how to unpin so
remarkable okay I Scott okay then I'm
doing here I just wanted to step out of
and like the queen bee three as my idea
I want to step out overnight c5 fork a
position is really okay for me but it's
not so easy to see how to make some
progress to be four
ok let's see 523 should be ok
95 query also gives them some there are
some points about blacks position that I
that are quite unreliable like the
position of the bishop won't be form so
okay you cannot really win the porn g5
Bishop to 395 queen three I'm attacking
e5 so that's not working rather
complicated him yeah politics that's
okay 95 Queen here I cannot take e for
due to Queenie for and that uses a piece
and the g5 it's not working due to
various things okay this kind of move
haha so he really wants to grab stuff
now sg5 that's a way to win the pond but
of course that weakens his position
considerably let's see night I'm not
quite sure this night okay I wonder do I
cheek on 66 or not i think i will take
so how to do it now rupee one maybe you
can go nitey to what after Queen f5 my
compensation is pretty substantial i
think and i can actually then take see
for how that was a hella stupid on
stupid home not very well thought out
pawn takes he had queen c5 check I was
still interesting action okay there is
also interesting when he says King
position is weakened what is he going to
like g4 I know okay going back that
should be the best diagonal takes Queen
takes doesn't help
probably anyway of Queen takes I have
Quincy seven just activating it's not
even doing that okay time morning how do
i get some rooks here into the game or
just Quincy 7i can takes you three we
already don't know this for Quincy seven
may be looking at f7 and looking at the
aid now it's playing well I can actually
take and then pin me I don't leave never
checked them whoa not a good game here
to kick off that session now okay hi
resign I was a bad game I probably good
position around here that is a pretty
good position actually okay maybe around
here i'm already doing stupid things I
don't know this should be a bit better
for white anyway maybe I have to play G
for that was the engine is giving but I
didn't have I didn't that that didn't
feel so easy to me that idea that I had
was interesting definitely i have d 6
now intermediate more farm that's very
good for wide acclaim I thats it's much
better than the game okay so but I saw
that
but that's really true this way okay I
can take f6 now that's that's it that's
a simple way to do it yeah why did i do
that i mean i thought i would always
have compensation here but maybe maybe
that's not really the case rook 2193 and
yeah you know the problem is I was
seeing I wanted to take with the f1 of
course that was the initial idea but
then I saw that check but what I didn't
do is I should I thought just one move
further because that check is complete
rubbish this is of course just excellent
for white ok and after this it doesn't
feel it's probably compensation but it's
a it isn't easy 25 is strong could have
taken a five already and here I don't
have sufficient play it's got group d
three coming now ma'am that's not good
yeah that is not very convincing in my
eyes my moves but I'm already clearly
worse there's nothing nothing great that
I can find or that there is to find that
that's the right phrase John yeah just
playing badly in the critical situation
something like this is pretty simple
actually now my rooks are much more
active and so here's just a question of
her now what should like do here it's
kind of it's not easy like this maybe at
night is hanging and then Queen f5 that
this is Sir this is tricky for black
yeah that wasn't it wasn't well played
ok well thanks for watching